[موسيقى]
اوزونا بس ناقصه فلوس اخر شيء توقعت هذا
الكرتون منتدى الجديد
وحنبيع
الحلوى خالته اقتباس فكرته من فين
طبعا رقمك بانه قصه حقيقيه حدثت في
السعوديه
ريال واللي انها الاسبوع الاول على الشباك
في السينما السعوديه لاقى اعجاب جدا كبير
من قبل الجمهور والنقابلته دخلت الهاشتاج
راح تلاقيه مئات التعليقات الايجابيه بشان
العديد من العناصر زياده الممثلين
الموسيقى التصويريه جوده الانتاج
الفيلم بشكل او باخر
خلاني افتكر جوال في الفوز حق ليونار
كميه الجنون كميه الفلوس كميه همم
زي ما تقولوا
الجراه في الاشياء اللي ممكن تسويها
بالفلوس فلم الهامور كان جيري كل
التصويريه موسيقى هشام نزيه اللي ما يعرف
هشام نزيه هو موسيقار ومؤلف موسيقي مصري
لكنه عالمي
اشتغل في اعمال عالميه واشتغل في اعمال
ضخمه جدا كان اخرها فيلم كيرو والجن
ومسلسل مون نايت مسلسل مارفل
[موسيقى]
الجميل اخصائي تجميل بانه الفخ اللي ابتلع
هناك وقالت انه على الرغم من ظهور محمد
هنيدي من منتصف الثمانينات من القرن
الماضي تقريبا في ادوار صغيره
ويصبح واحد من طليعه الشباب او النجوم على
الشباك السينما المصريه في مسيره رات انها
بدات في قطار لا يمكن ايقافه واكدت انه
نظريا لا يزال محمد هنيدي ايقونه لكن
عمليا وبتتبع بسيط مسيرته نحن تراجع كبير
بعد مضيء 10 سنوات من الزمن على النجاح
يعني من اواخر التسعينات والغايه 2009
وقالت انه نقطه بدايه الانحدار كانت من
عند امير البحار عام 209 وصولا لنبيل
الجميل الجمهور بدورهم قسم بشان الفيل
اللي لم يحقق ارادات كان يطمح لها هناك
ووصف الفيل بانه اقل من المتوقع
[موسيقى]
صور نبيل مسؤول عن المستشفى دلوقتي
في مقاله الاخيره عن حلم ينتظر النجم احمد
حلمي تحقيقه وهو تجربه الاخراج حيث تتوقع
ان يقع اختياره على منى زكي التجربه واللي
لم تفرض نفسها على حلمي يوما في اي من
الافلام بل على العكس حيث اؤكد الشناوي
انها الا طال ما اعطته مساحته وحاول طريقه
للنجوميه على شباك السينما بعيدا عنه في
وقت لم تعد فيه الاسماء الفنيه النسائيه
تتصدر الشباك وقال انه ربما سيكون
الاجتماع ما بين الزوجين الابراج بعد 20
سنه من الارتباطهم هو حلمي كمخرج بينما
تكون مولعه البطل النهارده حلمي بحكم همم
عنده دائما يتحدث عن فكره انه ممكن يخرج
فيلم وانا شايف ان هو يستطيع ان يلتقذ
فعلا فكره وهو له سابق جميله في اختيار
الافكار وفي ايضا كثيرا ما يضيف بعض مشاهد
او جمل حواريه
فلديه درايه بالدرامه بيذاكر كويس فيما
يتعلق بالتكوين
تواصل الفنانه غاده عادل تصوير احداث
فيلمها الجديد البطه الصفراء والمقرر فرحه
قريبا بدور العرض السينمائي حيث تزورنا
الكواليس وقمنا بلقاء نجوم الفيل ما بينهم
غاده عادل اللي تجسس دور الزعيمه عصابه
يتعاون معها الفنان محمد عبد الرحمن او
توته في عمليات السطور قبل ما يتورطوا
الاثنين في مشاكل كثيره وسط مواقف كوميديه
وطبعا كلمه قصه وحوار محمود عزت من ناحيه
اخرى انضمت الفنانه غاده عادل كمال لمسلسل
مع احمد السقا بعنوان وزن الريشه والمفروض
انه يعرض من ثمانيه حلقات على احد من
السعاده
يعني ظهور خاص كده في الفيلم بس اعتقد
يعني والله اعلم من الشخصيه اللي بالعبها
دي مبني عليها
احداث فيسبوك كلها
الناس اللي بالشكل ده الي بيمروا بالظروف
دي بيلبسوا ايه بيتصرفوا ازاي
قعدت مع المؤلف ومع المخرج
انا مش شخصيه تتعاطف معاها وتحبها وتصعب
عليك بالرغم انه يمكن في الاول يعني
تفتكرني يا شخصيه يعني غريبه مش تمام كده
حضرت بقى كل ده ازاي اتربي ازاي طلعت كده
ليه بيتكلم عن همم واحد اسمه دكتور فيه
اللي هو انا اعوذ بالله من كلمه انا يعني
بيعمل بحث رساله الدكتوراه
في علم النفس وبعدين بيلاقي نفسه متورط في
موضوع البطه
[موسيقى]